all right so many of you at home this
morning might be wondering are there
actually people
outside shopping already for this black
friday and the answers yes some stores
are already open this morning hector me
he is live outside the best buy near
maryland parkway in twain
with a look all right hector how many
people are out there this morning what's
the craziest thing you've seen so far
well you know the pushing and shoving
and the stampede of customers we've seen
in previous years
i can tell you that is not what we're
seeing this morning but we have seen a
steady stream of customers
not only waiting in the parking lot but
also going into the store
now things are slowing down but all
morning we've been seeing employees
running out with merchandise mainly ps5s
and customers also running out probably
because it's really cold out here
but retailers did a pretty good job at
avoiding
the massive crowd so they had a few
strategies including having no
door buster deals they went ahead with
posting a lot of those deals online
and providing curbside pickup so we're
at best buy because tvs will be the hot
item this year
according to a group that tracks product
sales npd group says practical items
like tvs
computer monitors and keyboards all will
be hot sellers you know
a lot of people are working from home
right now that follows a recent trend of
customers buying those kind of
things to help them work from home less
than an hour ago we
talked with one guy who told me he got a
great deal on a 65-inch sony oled tv
he said it was discounted a thousand
dollars off
but remember you can get many of those
deals online
a lot of the stuff that's in store you
don't even need to show up in person you
can just buy it and come pick it up
within maybe like half an hour so if
they have it you felt the need to go
into oh
i always like i want to see it in person
if i'm going to buy it
and here's a line of about 60 customers
who waited this morning for best buy to
open at five o'clock
in the morning you know this has been a
tradition for so many but analysts are
expecting a much slower holiday season
this year
here in nevada the retail association of
nevada says brick and mortar sales in
our state
could drop anywhere between three
percent and
eight percent from last year and we've
been talking with people all morning
long since we got here at five o'clock
this morning
and a lot of people are just waking up
eating
their thanksgiving day leftovers some
gravy stuffing
some turkey and making a whole day out
of it masks are being enforced and we
are told
that uh people are also being told to
social distance
as they shop around inside the stores
well that's the latest from out here
hector mejia reporting live
eight news now back to you guys all
right hector thanks so much for that
i've been out there before and there's
always
crowds of people so it does look
different this year all right alex let's
send it over to you